[Applause]
[Music]
Belgium the land of mussels and ships
craft beers and some of the best
chocolate in the world however
visualpolitik viewers in a few years
Belgium may be better known for being
the Narco state of the European Union
Yes Yes you heard me correctly it's most
important Seaport adverb has become the
largest Gateway for illegal narcotics in
Europe various underworld groups are
making a killing trafficking substances
such as cocaine and methamphetamine and
to maintain this business they are
willing to do anything so on
visualpolitik we have asked ourselves
several questions how has Belgium become
something like Pablo Escobar's European
dream how is this all affecting the
daily lives of Belgian citizens and more
importantly what is being done to combat
it today on visualpolitik we're going to
answer these questions but before we
continue I'm sure you've started the
year with some resolution or other maybe
to exercise more or spend less money on
a certain brand of coffee or to get
serious about a language well with
speakly all excuses are squashed with
speakly you can learn languages like
Spanish French German Italian and of
course English we know that some of you
are not native English speakers and one
of your goals is to improve your English
speakly offers you everything you need
to learn or reinforce a new language you
will learn new vocabulary practice with
oral written and listening exercises and
they even have a section with
recommended songs for you and take note
because speakley's methodology is proven
it has been proven to show results five
times faster than the usual apps by
practicing only 30 minutes a day you
could have a solid conversational level
in about three to four months don't wait
any longer stop making excuses and start
learning languages in 2023 with speakly
download the app which is available for
both Android and iOS and try it totally
free for seven days if you want to go
for the annual subscription take
advantage of the 60 discount for the
visualpolitik community we'll leave you
the link in the description
and where the European hub for narcotics
located in the heart of Europe adverb is
an atypical Port because it is not on
the coast but 80 kilometers or 50 miles
Inland at the mouth of the Shelt history
in fact it is precisely this peculiarity
that makes the port of adverb the second
busiest port on the European continent
[Applause]
[Music]
to give you an idea the port of adverb
has 50 kilometers that's 30 miles of
keys that are connected to the European
Hinterland by railroad waterways and
canals on these Keys 11 million
containers are unloaded every year in
total more than 235 million tons of
goods enter the old continent annually
using this port twice as much as just 20
years ago
11 million containers at Rough count
we're talking about more than 30 000
containers every day and just think
Maritime trade offers the same
advantages to drug trafficking as any
other industry containers transport High
volumes of goods at a relatively low
cost as you can imagine controlling what
arrives in each of these containers is
practically an impossible mission for
the 700 Customs agents at the Port of
Antwerp that's because the port's
figures are completely overwhelming
these 700 agents have to supervise 60
000 workers from Steve doors crane
operators and the rest of the port
professionals and of course as you can
imagine in such large baskets there are
always a few bad apples
the fact is that corruption has
penetrated the port of ant-verb over the
last few years underworld groups have
managed to infiltrate Port workers as
moles in this way they have the ability
to find out who might be more likely to
accept a bribe we are usually talking
about a lot of money several thousand
Euros for jobs as simple as providing
some information and if the worker in
question does not agree to be bought he
or she can always be intimidated with
threats that is why it is believed that
the number of people working for
criminal organizations in the port is
increasing
[Music]
through its tunnels with large format
scanners the port of adverb currently
monitors one out of every 200 containers
so you can imagine how crucial it could
be to have information about the
day-to-day business at the Port Customs
officers look for smuggled Goods
counterfeit goods and above all white
powders from Latin America and of course
I'm not talking about sugar or even salt
coca has become one of the queens of the
ant verb Harbor party
it is precisely for this reason that
trade with South America is particularly
targeted by Customs teams driver
traffickers take advantage of shipments
of fresh fruits such as bananas and
pineapples to hide their special
merchandise inside yeah that's right and
many of you will ask why in fresh fruit
well if you think about it this is one
of the main exports from South America
to Europe so in theory it should not be
a shipment that would put Customs on
alert another very important detail is
that we are talking about perishable
products which makes the rush to be
distributed quickly through the markets
much greater in addition a container of
fruit is just one of the thousands that
circulate through ant-verb every day so
the chances of hiding the narcotics are
enormous and the risk of being detected
is minimal
foreign
the business model of the underworld
groups is to ship as many containers
loaded with narcotics as possible on
mass they are aware that they can afford
to lose 10 to 20 of their cargo at
Customs such a loss would be fatal to
the profitability of any other industry
but not for drug traffickers especially
Colombian traffickers for whom Europe is
becoming their main Market
one of the keys to this modus operandi
is that the main profit in the cocaine
industry is not in retail sales or
production rather it is in
transportation according to estimates
the cocaine producers margin could be
150 of the cost of production the profit
margin of the sale to the consumer is
300 but in the case of Transport from
its place of origin to the final Market
this can reach 1500 depending on where
in Europe it ends up and more than one
of you may be wondering why are we
talking about Europe and not other
places well it is fundamentally a
question of profitability the street
price of cocaine is higher in Europe
than in the United States but wait a
minute because there are more reasons
foreign
director general of Belgian Customs
explains to us who has more interest in
having drugs flow to Europe than to the
North American Giant the Colombian and
other cartels they don't have to work
with the Mexican cartels which are in
between and who take them the most
profit of the drugs who is exported to
the United States
you don't have the Mexican cartels
involved with the the the Colombian
production so the question is who are in
this case playing the role of the
Mexican characters who are the middlemen
well it seems that they are mainly
groups from the Balkans distant
relatives of the albanians who crossed
paths with Liam Neeson in the movie
Taken these Mafia style groups have
built an Empire worth billions of Euros
they have made contact with Latin
American cartels and have expanded
shipping routes to Europe which is
boosting their profits the main
countries where cocaine is produced for
European clients are Colombia Peru and
Bolivia but be careful because
transportation is a different story
drugs are starting to be transported
from places that are not so tainted by
drug trafficking in the case of the
cocaine found in Belgium the drugs are
arriving from Ecuador particularly from
the container Port of Gaia quill we've
talked about this in Latin politic the
Latin American newsletter that patreon
members received so the drugs are
arriving from Ecuador but also from
Suriname the fact is that the drug trade
in adverb is growing and attracting
underworld groups from all over the
world organized crime is trying to
dominate this Market something that is
unleashing an unprecedented wave of
violence and the question is how is this
affecting the good people of Antwerp
well let's take a look
[Music]
Skyfall
in 2021 Belgian Authority seized 90 tons
of cocaine at the Port of Antwerp almost
40 percent of all cocaine seized in the
European Union for 2022 the numbers are
expected to have been very similar and
it is even possible that the Belgian
authorities forecast of reaching 100
tons seized during that year will have
been met drug traffickers are using
ant-verb as their gateway to Europe and
the volumes are increasing year after
year as Florence angelisi of Belgian
Customs acknowledges if you compare to
five years before it's up to 50 percent
more so every year we break a new record
and we would like to stop this record
these continuing records have brought
about a marked change in drug
trafficking to the European continent
traditionally cocaine traveled mainly
from Colombia and it was the southern
coasts of Europe that received the
shipments however that has changed there
are two Northern countries that have
just overtaken Spain as the preferred
countries of choice for the Pablo
escobars of the moment
Belgium and the Netherlands are now
Europe's major cocaine hubs europol
However the fact that cocaine seizures
have increased in Belgium is not
something that has fallen out of the sky
it is a result of two years of police
investigation culminating in what is
known as operation Sky ECC
o Sky ECC is the name of a Canadian app
that offers an encrypted messaging
service in case you didn't know
encrypting Communications is the first
subject in the professional criminals
handbook so it seems that Sky ECC was in
the top downloads for cocaine kingpings
that's why police forces in several
countries set themselves the goal of
cracking this app the investigation was
successful and intercepted one billion
messages one year after operation Sky
ECC was launched the results are
spectacular operation Sky ECC 888
suspects and 4.5 billion euros worth of
drug seized the fall of Sky ECC brought
to light a large network of legitimate
companies created expressly to import
drugs from South America to launder the
profits reaped it also revealed a bit of
Truth which is that the kingpins are not
hiding in big mansions of Brussels but
in luxurious Villas in places as exotic
and far away as Dubai so it is much more
difficult to catch them
[Music]
be that as it may 4.5 billion euros is
no small change and the underworld
groups did not take the sting lying down
they responded as you would expect from
the bad guys in the movie with a violent
Revenge that puts all belgians under
threat they want to cause fear and have
even attempted to kidnap Vincent Van
quikenborn the current Minister of
Justice after he announced a plan to
fight drug trafficking in adverb van
quickenborn himself has no doubts about
what is going on in Belgium and sums it
up in one word narco-terrorism
is
the truth is that Belgium suffered the
worst summer in 2022 in living memory in
terms of violence Brussels and Antwerp
made headlines with shootings arson
stabbings and even grenade attacks on
homes and businesses there is a battle
for territory and to control the
epicenter of cocaine in Europe because
the fact is that an uncomfortable truth
prevails despite the success of
operation Sky ECC
and this is because the cocaine Market
although illegal does not escape the law
of supply and demand despite all the
tons seized by the authorities the
street price of cocaine has not
increased and remains stable at around
50 euros per gram this is a sign that
the driver continues to enter Europe
very easily in other words we're talking
about an enormously lucrative Market
authorities arrested about 160 people in
the port of Antwerp in 2021 still it is
a city where it is as easy to get white
powder as it is to order a pizza and yet
it is probably still too early to speak
of Belgium as a narco state but let no
one doubt that in 10 years it could
become one if they fail to stop the
current Trend so the question therefore
is what do the Belgium authorities
intend to do to curb drug trafficking
and take note because this whole issue
has a political reading that is as
unexpected as it is surprising check it
out
[Music]
Flamenco against Vivaldi
anteverp is the most popular city in
Flanders a region that is home to a
powerful nationalism led by the new
Flemish Alliance this party has received
the most votes in the last three Belgian
Federal elections but it was only part
of the federal government during one
legislature and did not even lead it it
is most often part of the opposition and
its leader is Bart de Vive mayor of ant
verb for the last 10 years the Vive is
the leading political figure of Flemish
nationalism and is now taking advantage
of the drug-related violence in adverb
to attack the Belgian federal government
the Vivaldi coalition government
Vivaldi is the nickname given in Belgium
to the federal government Coalition that
since 2020 brings together
representatives of four different
political families the nickname refers
to the Four Seasons By The Italian
composer Antonio Vivaldi with the green
of the ecologists in body and spring the
red of the Socialist summer the orange
of the Flemish Christian democrats
Autumn and the blue of the Market Center
right as the winter
of course de vive's critics consider it
opportunistic to use drug trafficking
for political purposes in other words
they see it as inelegant to try to take
advantage of such a sensitive issue of
course that is up to the interpretation
of each individual what is no less
certain is that the mayor of Antwerp
declared a War on Drugs years ago and is
one of the few public Representatives
who dares to speak out on this issue
without mincing words take a look people
don't want to see that their line of
coke is tied to organized crime says
deviva the mayor of Antwerp has even
claimed that the federal government is
not doing enough to combat drug-related
crime because the social Elite assumes
drugs he also called on society to
reflect on the fact that drug use has
been normalized and demanded more
resources from the government to
strengthen Security in the port of
Antwerp and more powers for cities and
municipalities to deal with the violence
Unleashed by drug traffickers
the fact is that de Vive has become the
champion against the Narco Empire and
keep in mind that right now that could
have important implications for example
in the latest Federal elections the new
Flemish Alliance was weighed down by the
great rise of a radical far-right
pro-independence party the vlam's belong
which was isolated from the politics of
pacts for having a past in which it was
outlawed for being racist well now de
Vive wants to prevent this rise from
continuing in the next elections and
here his anti-narco campaign could come
in hand confederalism or nothing Bart
deviver warns ahead of the 2024
elections the Vive wants the Belgian
state to become a confederation of
Flanders and wallonia in order to be
able to govern the Flemish region
completely autonomously and we know what
that nothing means in Belgium politics
without the new Flemish Alliance and the
far-right pro-independence vlalms belong
in the equation to form a coalition
government it looks as if Belgium May
face another major political crisis with
an incumbent government that will be
prolonged CNA VA due to the fact of
agreement to form a new cabinet after
the elections be that as it may there is
still time for that and for the moment
adverb has more pressing problems
problems like this one custom sees so
much cocaine in Belgium that
incinerators can no longer keep up it's
hard to believe but Belgium's
incinerators are incapable of putting an
end to what the Antwerp prosecutor has
dubbed the cocaine Mountain
[Music]
the incinerators have neither the
capacity to burn so much cocaine nor do
the environmental restrictions for the
destruction of large quantities of drugs
allow it all of this raises security
concerns as it is feared that criminal
organizations may now attack these sites
to recover some of the Seas tons the
good news is that Vivaldi seems to be
reacting firstly because the federal
government has moved to increase drug
incineration capacity and fundamentally
because it has pledged resources to
fight drug trafficking 16th of September
2022 Belgian government unveils plan to
fight organized crime the Vivaldi has
pledged 300 million euros for a plan
called XXL it will be invested in
bringing more than 100 Customs officers
to the port of ant verb and adding five
more fixed scanners near the port
terminals so that at least all suspects
can be inspected Vivaldi has also heeded
the requests of the mayor of anteverp
and from now on municipalities will be
authorized to order the closure of
businesses suspected of having links
with drug Rings we're talking about
pizzerias coffee shops hairdressers that
are always empty but never close because
as they simply serve to launder a part
of the drug money I'm sure that even if
you don't live in adverb you also know
of such a business whatever the case the
questions are now over to you do you
think these measures will be enough to
stop drug trafficking in adverb or do
you think the underworld groups are
always one step ahead of the police you
can leave us your answers in the
comments if you found the video
interesting please like it don't forget
to subscribe to visualpolitik if you
haven't already done so thank you so
very much for being there all the best
I'm seeing you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you